hello I'm Katalin stayin I'm an
associate professor at the University of
Craiova Romania and we will have a
presentation about histopathological
image classification i'm daniel
Lichtblau
from Wolfram research and I will be
giving the second half of this
presentation
hello I'm Catalina Sturm
I'm from University of Craiova Romania
associate professor there I I'm not a
physician I'm working in computing
computer science but a few years ago I
been involved in a project that was
related was contained also physicians
and pathologists and I have to thank the
previous speaker she introduced us to
this world so that we don't have to to
provide so many details so what we
wanted to do among other goals was to
classify column cancer histopathological
images into four classes this is the
data set we mainly worked on so we had
the four classes back then normal grade
1 grade 2 and grade 3 when I got import
into this project my background was
pretty much related to evolutionary
computation and machine learning but
more related to numerical data less to
images so I I was actually hoping that
there is there somewhere possibility to
transform the images into numerical
vectors and then just use classifier and
my job would be kind of done but
unfortunately I did not really find an
easy way to do to do the CIE so I had to
do it the hard way
so at first how how these images were
obtained we had larger images from which
some crops were extracted the larger
images contained two also boundary
boundaries between norm
of tissue and cancerous tissue so there
are in this data set the light the light
and the instrumentation was similar for
the normal tissue and some parts of the
cancerous one so sometimes so every time
I think there are tissues that resemble
very much in light only between normal
tissue and cancerous tissue so of course
the normal tissue look like to Sita said
quite all right I mean they the plants
are very circled there there is not this
chaotic organization as we can see in
the other grades of cancer okay so as I
said our main focus was to to work on
this data set it had it was it contained
images but with magnification of 10
times and we had four grades there but
then we wanted to actually validate our
approach and we tried other datasets too
and among them the glass and break is
for this we had the only two classes we
did not have four so it's only normal
and cancerous and we could say that
actually break his represents four
different classification problems
because it contained four different data
sets four different magnification levels
forty times 100 200 and 400 and each one
of these was actually larger than the
other data sets we had so this is a very
large data set that is available
actually all these data sets are
available for download
for someone wants to go and test them so
what was my approach I actually followed
it this happened around five years ago
so I followed the usual guideline I mean
I had to pre-process the images to
segments to look for some components in
these images then extract some features
since then after after this we end up
with too many features so we have to
select out of these features the ones
that are important and finally apply a
classifier in order to reach the
conclusion to reach the class of open
image for each step there are many
options so many options for
pre-processing many options for
segmentations for segmentation for
feature extraction feature selection or
for diagnosis so we kind of tried some
some of these options we stopped at some
options which I was interested back then
into finding the glance and finding the
new clay and for these components I went
to compute morphological features like
area perimeter and also I went to other
features that involve the topology of
these components so that would be
Voronoi diagrams and Dolan I triangles
and for all these of course again area
and perimeter and different dimensions
we end up with 76 measurements having
also average median minimum maximum and
so on or so different statistics about
each measure and after this tried
several
so this is some kind of history what I
did before meeting Daniel and using
Mathematica
so all these were done in open CV with
C++ a lot of a lot of work and I went
over and to do some feature selection
then tried several options for feature
selection there to the they weren't that
proved to be the best one was actually
using the genetic algorithm to select
because I told you I have as a
background I have evolutionary
computation this is what I've been
working on so of course I had to use a
genetic algorithm at all and there's a
classifier the best classifier tried
several support vector machine appeared
to be the best the best choice by the
way I did not mention the classification
in the best the best situation was
somewhere almost eighty four percent for
this data set that contains four classes
which for for me and for the physicians
was for them it was not such good news
but for me it was I mean I was quite I
thought it was a good result for a poor
class problem classification problem
when presenting that those results I had
the opportunity to meet someone that was
using deep learning and we started a
collaboration we tried to apply this
convolutional neural network for our
data data set which led to better
results somewhere around ninety one
after tuning a lot the data set but
still not overfitting and very recently
back then I did not I was not quite you
to code in Python and to using
convolutional neural networks so I did
not try here more than just parameter
tuning but this year I tried rest net by
the way this result was not even
published ResNet 50 so transfer learning
and fine tuning and the result moved
even to 95% so which was of course very
very nice but now turning back when I
when I met Daniel at a conference he was
presenting I was standing in the room
and she was presenting something that I
was hoping to see from the very
beginning he had a method that
transformed images into numerical
vectors so from each image would obtain
some vector of about 300 values so I
thought this would be wonderful for for
my project so I would just transform the
images and I could classify them after
all
afterwards I talked to him he of course
wanted to to work together and he did
with this classifier he did better than
what I did with the seven steps
classifiers so the result was somewhere
around 88 89 percent which was quite
quite okay I mean it was I was happy
with it but then we had the opportunity
to use Mathematica I mean if we had a
lot of options there
there was this function that I found
really magical classified which she
actually accepts anything except
numerical data accepts images even sound
files and it could classify images so we
tried several options here many
classifiers two to four forties in
jeez we did not know back then exactly
what the classify function did how how
it did actually only yesterday we we
found out this conference that behind it
it has to share the secret with everyone
it has compositional neural network
behind so it actually produces 1,024
features so the features that are
produced by Alex net convolutional
neural network are extracted and fed to
the classifier next so the classifier
can can be applied on these numerical
values and the results from these were
better even better than then what Daniel
represented some of them were not better
but some were better and somehow we
managed to to combine these results so
among these classifiers we had the
random forest knife base K nearest
neighbors support vector machines
logistic regression neural network so a
simple neural network and the method
that Daniel presented and caught my
attention and this Fourier
trigonometrical transform plus principal
component analysis actually we as Daniel
we present next he will present the
second part of this presentation he will
she will actually show that although
this F DT plus PCA did not lead to the
best results overall it had a very
important role in leading to a better
results than what we previously obtained
okay I think yeah I'm miked up Thanks
okay so to save a bit of time we've cut
a little bit of information about the
details of this this F TT plus PCA I'll
just say in brief it's two steps of
dimension reduction we use some kind of
Fourier trig transform and take the low
frequency components that's step one and
then we flatten these these smaller
dimensional matrices into vectors we do
this with you know so each image now
becomes a vector and we do something
principal components like we subtract
the mean I think we take a singular
values decomposition and we drastically
cut the dimension there and we then feed
the resulting vectors into a the nearest
function in Mathematica so it's another
K&N type of approach however it behaves
very differently in terms of results for
our purposes than the K&N method for
classify so that you know it turns out
to be useful in its own right
oh okay so here's the results we got
over I think it was we did many many
randomized splits of 2/3 training 1/3
testing and the means for the averages
for all of these and the other
statistics you can see and so the the
FFT T plus PCA comes out basically in
the middle and actually very close to K
and in terms of the mean but well I'll
get to more about that later the SVM and
logistic regression did the best the
neural net was also somewhere in the
middle although we probably could I mean
we did the most naive thing possible
method goes to neural net and you know
something goes to either quality or
speed performance goal I guess
we didn't try to get get fancy with the
neural-net we if we had it probably we
probably could have made it do somewhat
better okay
so the next thing is to combine these
into an ensemble that it's sort of a
voting scheme so that you can get better
results than you could from any
individual classifier and so what we did
was we split our our tests up and we did
did a bunch of runs where we would tune
to get good weights for each classifier
so that these classifiers deliver
probabilities and or surrogates for
probabilities and what we want to do is
weight these and sum them and then the
highest sum determines what grade of
cancer of 0 through 3 you know the
highest some wins for our classification
okay so we did we wanted to optimize
these and and we did we used and
minimize in in Wolfram language with
differential evolution as the method
there's a reason for that which I will
probably just have to gloss over so yeah
I think I skipped this I think there's
another slide that's in hiding somewhere
here but rather than go through the
details I'll just convince you that it
sort of tame by showing the code you're
not there won't be a quiz but and and
yes it probably looks a bit cryptic but
it's short and the reason it's short is
because it actually isn't all that
complicated so what we're doing is
because the actual outcome is discrete 0
1 2 or 3 we subtract we take the
difference between actual and expected
you know our mistake in other words and
we square it I think that's what we're
doing here yes because we want to really
penalize errors that are off by two or
three more than errors off by one and
that turned out to be a pretty good
objective function to minimize and we
use differential evolution because my
experience at least and it's fairly
extensive is that it's a fairly robust
optimizer when your your function your
objective function is discrete valued
okay so we did 20 of these splits and we
did some careful looking and some some
some programmatic analysis to determine
which gave the best weights but in in
fact the weights that we got tended to
be pretty similar across these 20 runs
okay and so what were the weights
well the random forest is 6% and KN n is
fairly large and so is f TT plus PCA
despite the fact that they're from the
same general family of methods and the
neural net it's a very low weight and so
there's naive buys despite the fact that
they did well the neural net was a
middle pack performer SVM and logistic
regression the two best performers
individually are getting decent weights
but not nearly as large as the largest
of those so why is that okay so we use
Cohen's Kappa coefficients to be because
that's a reasonably good way of
assessing correlation when you're
dealing with categorical data we use
this and we find that the Fourier
transform plus PCA method is more D
correlated from the others than than any
other pairings and so it it has the
lowest coefficient in in every row
except of course for the last row where
where we're comparing it to itself and
so what does this mean it means that
this method is making its mistake
in different places and by and large
from the other methods and so when it's
wrong the others tend to out vote it
anyway when it's right it's fairly it's
heavier weighting tends to overcome the
you know the the fact that the others
are several the others might be wrong
okay so it's so it's an offset it's it's
a nice balance okay
hello okay so here's the results oh my
gosh did I show the results for a media
tree I didn't I skip right over okay so
the results are we get 98% correct on
this four-way classification that's not
bad
so and most misses are off by one and
the bad news of you know there was one
person who was perfectly healthy who got
a grade three report and you can die of
a heart attack as easily as cancer so
maybe that wasn't such a good thing to
tell that poor patient but you know so
there's room for improvement but as
confusion matrices go that one there's a
lot of values that are either zero or
very close and most of the mistakes
really were between category 1 and 2 or
level 1 and 2 and and level 2 and 3 okay
for these other tests glass there's
broken into two sets and we did 95
percent these are some it's a small test
set so 95 percent and ninety percent or
it's like you know 19 out of 20 and 18
out of 20 brake hisses hard and so our
mix goal really is to do better on that
why is it hard it's because you're all
of your tissue samples are from tumorous
tissue
it's just benign versus malignant but
there's no normal tissue and some of the
benign a certain class of those these
are breast cancer or breast tumors a
certain class of the mid 9 to another
class of the malignant so this this is a
hard test
by the way we we did this without
changing the weights that we had
optimized for for immediate treat so you
know may it may may make sense for us to
react amaizing
okay so I'm just getting pretty close to
out of time but I think I'm also close
to out of slides yes okay so what did we
do
it's a one step classifier no
segmentation no for I know I know no
hard core image processing or or
computational geometry some of my
colleagues might be disappointed to hear
that but sorry the pathologist just you
know they want a diagnosis so this is
based on machine learning and and its
end to end it was optimized for a
particular data set it does tolerably
well on others I say so no tuning
necessary yeah take that with a grain of
salt
maybe we should retune a bit for
different types of cancer tissue room
for improvement yes there's plenty break
has even though we're getting 80 to 90
percent on that test set
week we could do better I think and so
this might involve different machine
learning methods and maybe you know
going harder at it within neural net
that that might be better suited for
this particular class of images other
things I've been thinking about and
getting ready to work on color
deconvolution because the slides are not
evenly colored the H&E staining and
deconvolution tends to offset that so a
pathologist really needs those stain
slides but but a neural net might
actually get you know overly focused on
on the amount of color when when that
varies just because of the way the the
tissue sample was done other things
related use rotations and of both
training and test images to sort of
eliminate edge or reduce edge effects
where where tissue boundaries kind of do
funny things
and I would like to find a better
dimension reduction scheme but I don't
have one yet okay so I think that really
was the last slide it really was
okay thank you very much
[Applause]